in this thrilling conclusion to our
video on training big models in the
cloud I'll help you scale your compute
power from machine learning well our
training have enough resources stay
tuned to find out in our previous
episode we talked about the problems
that are encountered when your data is
too big to fit on your local machine and
we discussed how we can move that data
off onto the cloud to have scalable
storage today we move on to the second
half of that problem getting those
compute resources rankle together when
training larger models the current
approach involves doing training in
parallel what this means is that our
data gets split up and sent to many
worker machines and then the model must
put the information and signals it's
getting back together to create the
fully trained model now you could spin
up some virtual machines and install the
network live arrays now work them
together configure them to run
distributed machine learning and then
when you finish you'd want to take down
those machines while this may seem easy
to some it can be a challenge if you're
not familiar with things like installing
GPU drivers and debugging compatibility
problems between different versions of
the underlying libraries so today we'll
use cloud machine learning engines
training functionality to go from Python
code to train model with no
infrastructure work needed the service
automatically acquires and configures
resources as needed and shuts them down
when that's done training there are
three main steps to using cloud machine
learning engine packaging your Python
code creating a configuration file that
describes the kind of machines you want
and submitting your train job to the
cloud let's see how to set up our
training to take advantage of this
service we move our Python code from our
Jupiter notebook out into a separate
script on its own let's call that file
task pi this is going to act as our
Python module which will be called from
other files now we want to wrap tasks
that PI inside a Python package Python
packages are made by placing the module
inside another folder let's call it
trainer and placing an empty file
underscore underscore init underscore
underscore dot PI alongside tasks a PI
so our final file structure is made up
of a folder called trainer containing
two files the Anita PI and the test at
piyo files while our package is called
trainer our module path is trainer dot
tasks
if you wanted to break out the code into
more components you would include those
in this folder as well for example you
might have say a util dot pie in the
trainer folder once our code is packaged
up it's time to create a configuration
file to specify what machines you want
running your training you can choose to
run your training with just a small
number of machines as few as one or many
machines with GPUs attached to them
there are a few predefined
specifications which make it easy to get
started and once you grow out of those
you can configure a customer
architecture to your heart's content
we've got our Python code packaged up
and we have our configuration file
written out so let's move on to the step
you've all been waiting for the training
it's a submitter training job we'll use
the g-cloud command line tool and run
g-cloud ml engine jobs submit training
there's also an equivalent REST API call
we specify a unique job name the package
path and module name the region for your
job to run in and a cloud storage
directory to place the outputs of your
training be sure to use the same region
as where your data is stored to get
optimal performance once you run this
command your Python package is going to
get zipped up and uploaded to the
directory we just specified from there
the package will be run in the cloud on
the machines that we specified in the
configuration you can monitor your cane
job in the cloud console by going to ml
engine and selecting jobs there we will
see a list of all the jobs we've ever
run including the current job you can
also see a timer on how much time the
job is taken so far and a link to the
logs that are coming out of model our
code exports the train model to our
cloud storage path that we have provided
in the job directory so from here we can
easily point the prediction service
directly at the outputs and create a
prediction service as we learned about
in episode 4 serverless predictions at
scale using cloud machine learning
engine we can achieve distributed
training without dealing with
infrastructure ourselves as a result we
can spend more time with our data simply
package up the code add that
configuration file and submit the
training job if you want the
nitty-gritty details on tensorflow as
distributed training model check out
this in-depth talk from the tensorflow
dev summit but for now remember spend
less time building distributed systems
and more time with your data a training
your model using cloud machine their
pitch i'm yu Fang Guo and thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures if you enjoyed it please go
ahead and hit that like button and for
more machine learning action be sure to
subscribe to the channel to catch future
episodes right when they come out
[Music]